hello uh
thank you very much for joining
my name is daniel uremia i'm webcasting
from boston from massachusetts general
hospital
and i'll be talking today
about
cells
and particularly about cells that move
and why they move and
why is that important
and if you have been listening to other
talks you realize that
these talks are mostly
either talking about
patient
from the perspective of the doctors
and
dealing with
patient and imaging of the organs
and house metastasis form
or
the other
large majority of the talks are on the
other end of the spectrum talking about
proteins
and genes and these are more molecular
biology oriented
in the middle bridging this to
sides are the cells and the organelles
they are
the
reason why is metastasis form and there
is a starting point for studying
proteins and genes
and
when we talk about cancer cells in
particular
there are a number of properties that
everyone agrees that receptor
this cells have
and
they are outlined in various reviews one
of the reference reviews for this is uh
from the year 2000 and more recently
updated
um if you look at this properties you
see that many have to do is the growth
of the cells with uh angiogenesis which
is
immune response
but if you think about
the practical end point
99 of the death and cancer are due to
metastasis
so the cancer cells that are in the
primary tumor when it forms they have
somehow to
reach distant tissues
and that's where tissue invasion and
metastasis properties
come in and
this is what we think is probably the
most important
feature
of the cancer cells
because if we could let's say
by some means stops invasion of the
cancer cells
and stops metastasis
all the other several properties that
these cells withdrawal converge to
formation of
benign tumor
that grows and we can excise
all the trouble starts with the cells
moving away from the tumor forming
metastasis at distant sides
so that's
what we
started to investigate now just to make
sure
that we are actually on the same line
i will first ask um
you to see how many of you have seen
cancer cells moving before
and i'll post this question as a poll
and he'll answer and in a few slides
we'll see what the results are
okay so
talking about cell migration
i have
we most of the time we talk about uh
what is
uh called chemotaxis so if you have a
cell at point a and have a source of
chemoattractant at point b that
diffuses in the environment and the cell
at point a is
responding to this
chemicals the cell is going to move from
point a to point b
and that's what we call chemotaxis
the other thing
i want to
put into perspective is how fast the
cells are moving compared to human
activities that you see in the center of
the slides
uh human working running
that's
about one meter per second and then to
the right of that we have
other modes of transportation the
automobile the
airplane
that's about one or tourist magnitude
faster and then at the extreme we have
the speed of light
now if you look at the left of what the
human activities are you see
some measures of cells moving
hepatocytes
and
neurons and the fastest
of the cells in our body there's
neutrophils we move about
10 to 50 microns a minute
and you see that speed is
at least five folds magnitude below what
human
eye is
used to seeing so
throughout the presentation i'll show
you what they call time-lapse movies
where you take pictures of the cells
uh every
10 minutes and then we put these frames
together in the movie that we
run very quickly
and the last thing
that is important and
is
the tools that we use for studying cell
migration
and i see that many of you
have
cn moving cells
and here are some of the tools that you
are probably familiar with
all these tools
you see here's a
description and the picture and the ear
when this
essay was initially developed
and if you look at the wound healing
assay where you put cells in the
monolayer and they scratch the surface
and you look at how
quickly the cells are
closings want that is from 1940s it has
almost 70 years old assay
another one that is commonly used is
what is called transfer assay
where you put the cells on one side of a
membrane you put the chemoattractant on
the other side
and then
you wait and then after 24 hours were
to base what more
you count how many cells made it to the
other side as a membrane
um with this assay you don't
see the cells moving you just count how
many cells were on the other side of
this membrane so you don't know if the
cells actually moved
or if they uh
a fuel of cell mold and then they pray
divided on the other side
with the one healing the problem is you
see the cells but
it's a
very
very crowded so it cannot distinguish
individual cells
there are two assays of microbial cells
sigmon chambery assay that give you this
single cellular solution but they are
very low throughput
so
these are the main tools now in the past
10 years new technologies emerged
led by microfluidic technologies that
allow us to
look at
cell migration
more precisely
and there are
several technical problems that this
microfluidic devices solve one is they
can make gradients
that are more stable by combining fluids
of different concentrations so the
gradients can be stable for
hours and days
you can switch between gradients very
quickly you can invert the direction of
the gradient you can make gradients of
various shapes
linear gradients and
radial gradients
now
um
what all this essay has in common in the
end and
with remains uh issue
with this assays
is
that most of the times the cells move on
flat surfaces
so
for those of you you know one-third of
you who said you've seen cancer cells
moving this movie is probably familiar
it shows uh
cell line mdam do be
231 cancer cells
moving
on
flat surface
there is a chemotactic gradient of
growth vector that is
with higher concentration at the bottom
of the image
and
if you track all these cells if you have
enough resolution and don't
lose the cell that you are tracking you
get the picture like someone showed on
the right where you have the trajectory
of the cells
that are very convoluted
the cells change speed quite often they
change direction very often
so if you look at this as an engineer
um
this represents a problem so
because if you have to analyze this it's
a very noisy information that you have
to deal with
so
with all the advances in microfluidics
we still face a problem of noise even if
we make the gradient perfectly stable
even if we control the environment
that's a problem so that's where our
work started couple of years ago
and
the way we approached the problem was by
thinking well
in the body
cells in general not only cancer cells
but to all the other cells at home
don't move on flat surfaces most of the
time they
migrate through tissue which is not a
homogeneous
environment but it's most of the time
very heterogeneous and there are
preferential pathways
that the cells can take
if you think about breast cancer
invading the first time the cells invade
this along
lymphatics
and
that's what doctors
is one of the first question doctors ask
when they
come into contact with a new patient who
is cancer is did the cancer reach the
lymph node it's a very important
piece of information but the way the
cells get to the lymph node is most of
the time through the lymphatics so
preferential tract
if you talk to pathologists they will
tell you that when they are looking for
cancer cells invading from let's say
pancreatic cancer
as you see on the right
side image they'll look for this cancer
cells along nerve fibers or along
blood vessels
because that's a preferential
path for pancreatic cancer cells to
invade
and if you talk to people that
do
in therefore imaging like you see in the
middle bottom
section of the
figure
they
know that when the implant cancerous
cells in
in a
model
they will see these cancer cells
invading the long collagen fibers
okay so with this information with this
knowledge we said well can we put
some microfluidic tools to work
and provide us with a more heterogeneous
environment and this is a schematic of
what we did
instead of culturing cells in what is
the standard
cell culture dish like astronomers
left
we
included
a microfluidic device
in the petri dish that is
makes a series of channels in between
the device and the bottoms petri dish
you can see
in the bottom image a top view of the
device where the cells are sitting on
one side
there are a series of channels
next results
that are 10 by 10 microns 600 micron
long collagen coated and the image will
happen every 10 minutes for six hours
and
here in the next slide i'm going to show
you
what we saw the first time when we run
this experiment
on the left we have cells with our
breast cancer cancer cells
and
images are taken every 10 minutes for
about 6 hours you see the cancer cells
quickly entering the channels and
migrating very
persistently
through the length of the channel until
they come out
the fastest cell
reaches
the end in about two or three hours
so this is
really fast and persistent
and these are the same cells that you've
seen earlier in the previous movie
so
for those of you who are more
mathematically inclined i have this poll
where i'm asking you to estimate
um how long it will take
in this cell if it's moving at 200
microns an hour to go about 10
centimeters
which is the distance
um
that is usually between let's say a
breast
cancer tumor
and the lymph node so that's about four
inches
you don't have to calculate very
precisely but i think your orientation
is right
these are very fast moving cells so if
these cells were to live with tumors and
go through the lymphatics they'll reach
lymph nodes pretty fast
yes
well
i can see many of you say that it's two
days that's that's a little bit fast
uh
it's more about three weeks
which in in terms of um
cancer evolution it's a very fast very
aggressive
evolution
so
how is the device looking like
this is one schematic of this
device it's a cell culture disk that has
a glass bottom
it's placed on top of microscope
and
the device itself
looks very much like a doughnut
um
yeah
you see in the blue image on the top
right
and it has a center hole where you put
the cells and then around that hole you
see the shadow of the channels through
which the cells are going to migrate
and then you can place this
devices in 96 well plates and
24 uh well played and do
several time of
movies at once
okay so um
yes i see that if there is a draw
in the poll about how fast the cell move
between two days and
20 days
as i told you that's a very
aggressive
tumor about 20 days and then
200 days these are probably less
aggressive tumors but we
don't
we'll get to this we'll get back to this
at the end of this presentation
okay um
so
i'll make a short parenthesis now before
moving forward
about how we make these devices because
this is a unique technology
that we have here massachusetts general
it's a technology it's a clean room
environment it's technology borrowed
from the electronic industry
and the way it works is
shown in this picture we start with the
silicon wafer one which we uh caught the
thin layer photoresist
we exposed with photoresist through uv
light through a photo mask
and then
we develop like you do with any photo
photography techniques
and we end up with a series of
structures on top of the silicon wafer
um that you see in the lower left corner
and this
structures can be down to micron size
yes i have my pointed back so these are
the structures on top of silicon wafers
that can be
controlled both in width and in height
and
we use this
to
mold a silicone material
another
elastomeric material is a silicone is
the same that is being used in
prosthesis
in patients is biocompatible it's the
same silicone that you use in the
kitchen
work and
we have a sealant that you can buy from
hardware store
so we
prepared this
material from uh
one molecular base and the cross linker
we mix them
uh two very well
and then we pour this material on top of
silicon wafer and we bake it for we cure
it for a couple of hours
and
at the end what we have
is
mold that has the features
is a copy is a replica of the features
that runs the silicon wafer
next step is to place this wafer on the
glass slide it once the bottom class of
played
and the way you do the bonding between
this uh struck
that with this material that has
microscale structures and the glass
is
by playing a
little trick using oxygen plasma
and what that does it activates the
hydroxyl groups on the silica and the
silicone groups on the silicon
and
then when the two surfaces are
so this is the activation and then when
the two surfaces are being put together
the covalent bond forms between the two
materials
and that creates a very strong seal
between the elastomeric material and the
glass
so now going back to the experiments
were to do with cells
um
obvious observations of cells moving
through channels relevant for what is
happening in people and here is one
experiment that we did in parallel
using our devices and
an animal model and we have one cell
line mdamb231
cells
breast cancer cell lines that were
transfected with hairpins that inhibits
make one of the genes controlling
metabolism
and in the left
on the left
um
here you you can see there's a
difference that we measured with our
device between the cells that move
between the two cell lines
in the movie you can see how the cancer
cells invade through these channels
through the gel
uh initially they go as collective
migration but
after about 24 hours some of the cells
break away and evade faster
it's pretty much along the lines of how
we think tumors invade and what people
doing animal models have tumors have
seen
and then we have um as you can see
on the right graph
we have the results from the animal
model we have the number of metastases
that the two cell lines form and the
cell line that moves faster in our
device generates more
of the lung metastasis in the animal
model
so we have a measure of how relevant
this assay could be for
individual
situations
uh other interesting things that emerge
from our study is that there is an
optimal
size for the channels
that makes the cell move better
and
that optimal size is
for channels that are
about
100
micron squared so 10 by 10 microns or
is the same size of lymphatic or same
size of a
manual capillary
if interestingly enough if you
go to larger
size of the channel
you see that the cells
don't migrate that effectively and if
you look at the movie
shown below you can see how the cells
wander inside the middle of the channel
and they lose the persistence of
migration
on the other hand if it makes the
channel smaller than the 10 by 10 cross
section than the cells hell hard time
going through the channels
one of
you is asking
is this
the optimum is there an optimal channel
size that is dependent on the cell line
and the answer is
yes
um
if they are
cells that are much smaller
in size cancer cell lines that would go
to
better to smaller channels
and uh there are larger cancer cells
that would
move better
through
larger channels
however the difference is not that great
they are all in between 80 to 100 micron
square
cross section
in the middle you actually see a picture
of
results that we have from
different cell lines
and
it's probably difficult to read but um
on
x-axis we have different cell lines
starting from the longer the left and
the colon cancer cell line on the right
and on the
y-axis we have the velocity
that uh in microns per hour that these
cells move going from 0 to 200 microns
per hour
and
you see that different cell lines move
with different average velocity which is
not surprising
you can see that the cells that are
satellites that are known to be more
aggressive like lung cancer
cell line
they are moving faster than
cell lines that are known to be less
aggressive
like the colon cancer
and
another thing that i want to point out
is
you notice how
wide the distribution of
values for velocity is
in each population of cells even though
these are clonal cell populations so
uh all the cells the cell lines are
supposed to be identical in
turn at least in terms of
the
genes that they have um there is a broad
spectrum of velocities ranging or this
magnitude from about 20 to about 200
microns per hour
okay
so another thing that i want to say is
that
this is definitely active migration
there is nothing pushing the cells
through the channels
if we um
associants uh
plot one's
right if we inhibit actin
polymerization using cytokinesis
the cells stop completely
and within
an hour after removing cytokinesin the
cells resume migration
so
the question is
what makes these cells move through
these channels
and
as engineers we focused on
there's a global picture of what is how
the environment
helps with cells migrate persistently
through channels and for this
because we can design these channels and
we can make them in any shape we
designed these devices
that we thought would be more
challenging for us migrating cells
so
if you look
on the left side of the image you see
the maze that we
made connecting the cell compartment to
the outer compartment
there are several
bifurcations along the way where the
cells have to make decisions
on the right side you see
the picture of the entire device
the cells are placed in the middle in
the cell compartment
they go to the bottom of the tear to the
glass but then um
the only way for them to get out of this
device is tools
through this array of mazes that is on
on the side there are 16 mazes that they
can take on the way out
and i have a question for you
which is
if a cell makes random decision and
there are four bifurcation points in
this maze
what do you think in terms of
how many of
100 cells would eventually reach the
exit
if they are making random decisions
okay so the first bifurcation half of
the cells to go
to a dead end half of these cells should
go
forward
and
let's see i'm waiting for you most of
you to respond because next slide i'm
going to show you what actually happens
so
then the movie that i'm going to show
you is going to be one cell
that is a pc9
lung cancer cell that is
transfected as a gfp marker
that is just for better visibility of
the cell
and
you'll see it going through the amazing
about 12 hours
okay now i see most of you responded
that it's
less
than
okay this change
it's somewhere less than 50 percent of
the cells are gonna make it through
that's what most of you think that's
and
it's actually split between those let's
say less than five cells in less than 50
cells
okay so everyone pretty much agrees that
will be less than 50 percent of the
cells
going through its maze
um
yes so let's see what happens in the
movie
the cell is entering from the bottom
and you see the time and it makes it
true with almost no mistake
and
if you look on the right we tested this
is the same cell going through again and
again
but you see the statistics for a larger
number of cells
on the right side there's a slide
and you see that different cell lines
go with different deficiency through the
maze but overall
what is shown in red
more than 50 percent of the cells this
is this would be the fifty percent
um
threshold uh most of the cells
go through the maze more than fifty
percent so
they are not going through this maze by
chance
they are making some decisions
and
this is surprising because if you look
at the device this device is sitting at
the bottom of a petri dish
and there is
no gradient that we imposed from the
outside we gave the cells absolutely no
cue
on
how to go out
and
the cells they don't have the
high-level view that the hell of the
maze they just enters the maze and they
they guide their migration through
so for us
this
engineer's challenge was well
how is this possible
this is not magic this is
with ourselves these are cell lines
um we should be able to figure out what
is
uh making the cell small
and just to make sure that what we do is
meaningful we tested the human
pancreatic cancer cells that we um
with help with surgeon we collected from
a
patient that had pancreatic cancer and
you can see here the cells going through
the mains where it's one cell first and
then there's the second cell
going through these cells
it's a little bit harder to see because
these are primary cells we have no
translators any fluorescent markers we
are not stained with any marker
so in thinking about the problem
and how it works um
it's a little bit difficult for you to
see because slide didn't come out very
well but
we have
let's see
at time zero
we have the cells on the left side
and
in the cell compartment
and then we have media fillings the
channel
this is put some lines this is the top
of the channel and then it has the outer
compartment
and
the cells are sitting in the media about
an hour
or
later when the cells start moving
the fact that the orient
tells us that there must be some
guidance and the cells must have changed
the environment in which they are
in some way and
we thought that would be by cells
consuming something out of the media and
creating a gradient
around them
so
what could
that thing
be
so we started the associant's image once
right to start doing some
calculations
and we said well can it be oxygen oxygen
is being consumed by all the cells quite
a lot
but then it diffuses through the media
very fast
and the gradient that forms around cells
in the device
through the channels
is very very shallow it's below 0.01
percent
so
it's
very unlikely that the cells follow an
oxygen gradient to migrate through these
channels
we then thought maybe it's a glucose
and or glutamine
because
these are little bit larger molecules
they diffuse
slightly slower and the cells consume
quite a lot of glucose and glutamine in
particular glutamine the cancer cells
and
our calculations show that the gradient
of maybe 0.1 percent will form between
the central compartment where the cells
are and the outsiders device
through the channels
and
then
that we pursue this idea but cells are
not really responding to gradients and
glutamine even if a gradient of 10
percent is
presented
so
that's not the answer what turns out to
be the answer is
epidermal growth factor egf which is
present in the media
at nanomolar concentration
it is being uptaken by its
cancer cells through the receptors
and
it is known
to stimulate
directional migration of cancer cell
epithelial cells in general
when it's
in the gradient so
we had this three conditions coming
together
each year being internalized by
epithelial cells egf
gradients being able to direct cancer
cell migration
and
egf being present in the plasma with
concentrations that
are such that
when the cells
in the channel uptake egf
there is limited
diffusion of egf towards the cell
and because of that a depletion zone of
egf forms around the cell and the
gradient that is
larger than
bio calculations and then larger than
about five percent
at one hour
so that is
um
what he said okay
that is what is guiding the cells
through channels
now how do we
show that um you know all these
calculations are fine
the engineers may be
happy with those but um
what other profit we have the tgf can be
as a guiding factor
for the cell's true channels
and that the self-generated gradient is
guiding the cells
so for this we simplified the maze a
little bit we made the bifurcation
channel
and you see here against uh fluorescent
green fluorescent detect this line cell
going from the cell compartment at the
bottom to the outer compartment
and on this
picture
you see the time with which pictures are
being taken
and
this is the same cell going on again
again it's not
it's not that all the cells go through
the same following same pattern but
basically if we look at how
many of the cells orient to go
is the right way out and the way the
dead end
we see a dependence uh with egf
concentration which is very
interesting because it's a bell-shaped
and with there's an optimal
concentration of egf
that is different for different cell
lines for mda cells it's about
0.1 nanograms which is equivalent to 5
fbs
in the media for
pc9 cells that is
is maximum it's about one nanogram per
ml
but the fact that we have a bell-shaped
curve tells us that
egf
could be
the factor orienting these cells if you
don't have vgf hence media as a cells
cannot orient at all
and
if you have too much egf
then
like this gradient of
egf cannot form a round cell to guide
the cells out
the speed of the cells interestingly
enough doesn't change much
it's
as you see in the plots below
its only
orientation
that changes
and then
we run some other experiments where we
block
this
egf signaling using
specific
inhibitor
called erisa
and
as you can see with very increasing
concentration of eraser
in the x-axis
the as the ratio of cells that takes the
right path through the bifurcation
is
decreasing for the cells that are
sensitive like cmda cells shown in black
with
concentration above
0.02 micromolar of irisa they start
losing directionality
whereas the pistonized cells
that are used that have mutation that
makes them insensitive to this eraser
they continue to move
with good orientation even in the
presence of large
of the inhibitory
and then
the
most definite experiment that we did is
one where we gave the
entering channels a choice
when
going through the channel
to go
to a side chamber
that
has you can see here that has a
different concentration of egf that's
concentration that is in outer in the
outer compartment
and we gave us choices of different
concentrations but also changing the
length of the channels
and
from the calculations of the gradient
you can
see that
the slope of the gradient when the cell
is set to bifurcation
is different
towards the side chamber or towards the
outer compartment
and it also depends
on the concentration
of the factor that is
right as bifurcation
what does that mean is that
if we
fill the entire device
with the same media present everywhere
so the concentration in the side
chambers concentration out is the same
then
so this is the case um
when a cell reaches a bifurcation
showing
with the orange blood
there should if if the cell is not
altering the environment it
shouldn't make any difference if it goes
to the left or to the right
the gradient
to the left and to the right is going to
be zero because there is no
concentration difference between the
bifurcation and the side chamber
however if the cell is consuming
something from the media
it is going to go towards the side
uh chamber because it's a shorter route
towards higher concentration
and
depending on how we
change the concentration of different
factors in the media
we can get different answers so for
example if we change the concentration
of egf
then the cells are going to go towards
side this high energy of concentration
if we
have
the same concentration of egf but the
cell is not consuming cgf we will see
an equal split of the cells going
towards the outer compartment or the
side chamber
i'll be happy to answer more
questions you have about this system
that we used
this
control for this experiment is obviously
one where
compartments inside chamber and the
outer compartment have
equal length channels where
the only thing that would matter for us
the decision of the cell is going to be
the concentration
ratio between the two
and when we tested this system with both
one to one length ratio three to one
length ratio
for various
cell lines
we
uh see
the decision making of the cell it's
bifurcation was in agreement with our
predictions whenever we had
the same concentration in side chambers
and the outer compartment
and shorter channels towards the side
chamber
the cells
chose to go towards the side chamber
whenever we had
and even more
even when we had half of the egf
concentration as a side chamber
compared to what was in the outer
compartment the cells turned towards the
side chamber more often than they did to
the outer compartment
and that is
possible only when the cells are
actively consuming egf and the
concentration of egf in front of the
cell when it reaches a bifurcation is
less than a quarter of what is
concentration outside
okay um
we tested
also other mechanisms
that could guide the cells and
excluded them in a series of experiments
that
i'll
work very quickly through
so in the top panel you see
a system where you have blood channels
that are straight followed by at the end
by very narrow channels through which
the cells cannot squeeze
and
what we observed was that the cancer
cells entering these blood channels they
went all the way to the end
and they stayed there they didn't turn
back
we then turn back even when we had
as shown in the second picture we made
the channel larger channel in the form
of u shape so
presumably a cell could
migrate
through
the channel and then if it just follows
a larger space
like mechanical guidance
it will turn back and go towards the
cellular compartment
in reality what
um in experiments what we observe is
that most of the cells actually
stop at the tip of the eu
and they go back and forth
for a very short distance but they
most of the time stay right there
we tested also
conditions whereas the cells
have the option of a shorter
channel going back to a cell compartment
towards the longer one to the outer
compartment and the cells turn
and move towards the outer compartment
most often
there is also mechanical guidance that
we tested and the interaction between
cells in the lower panel you see that
we did an experiment where you looked at
how often a cell enters
a channel when which another cell is
already being present and that shows
that the cells
avoid
dead end channels when each other cells
are present
okay so
with this tools um
we are very good at testing now some
migration of cells and we are looking
for some extreme cells that move very
fast or very slow and for this we
organized what we call the cell base
and if you are interested working with
cells
if you know people working with cancer
cells and interested in migration
uh
you have them registered and
will be happy to
include them in two surveys and
we will give prices for the best sales
to win but overall i think we'll learn
quite a lot if we find some extreme
sales betas very well oriented or don't
orient at all
um
for the last 10 minutes of my talk i
want to bring up
one more level of detail
for the migration of these cancer cells
so you remember early on as a
presentation i told you that
when we looked at different cell lines
we've seen
quite a broad range of velocities for
these cells
and
the question was why
even the thermal population you would
have so much difference between cells
that move slow
and cells that move fast
and this is true for all the cell lines
that we tested very broad range
so one of the hypotheses that we have
was
well
maybe the internal organization of the
cell
is responsible for how the cells move
how the cell is organizing its
inside
its organelles
the nucleus mitochondria the endoplasmic
reticulum and some cells do
this organization better than others you
know it's something comparable to okay
you have to
if you look at cars and you compare
different cars you may come up with
conclusion that cars that have here will
traction
are faster than the cells with frontal
forward
drive
so we looked at mitochondria and here is
a movie that shows
cells moving through the channels
and we stain the nucleus in blue and
mitochondria in red
and
we
did this in order to quantify precisely
this ratio
between the position of the mitochondria
inside the cell
we
looked at how much red is in front of
the nucleus using this
schematic shown here
and what we found was that indeed
cancer
and this is true for
different cell lines
and for different channels of different
sizes
the cells that have mitochondria at the
front shown in blue
represented in the blue bar they always
move faster and more of the cells
than the rest of the population so
having the mitochondria at the front
seems to be
giving the cells
some advantage
in terms of how fast they can move
through channels
um
here in this image you can see once the
x-axis we have the localization index
that we define
where one is a cell that has all the
mitochondria at the front
0.5 is where the cells have mitochondria
equally distributed between front and
back and
less than 0.5 cells that have more
mitochondria back and on the y-axis you
have the average velocity
in one plot and we have
this persistence in the other plot and
you can see that the cells that have
mitochondria at the front
they are
these cells
they are both more persistent
and moving faster than the rest of the
cells
in larger channels this dependence
between
where mitochondria is localized and the
speed and persistence is lost
so
we we ran this experiments to see if
that
is apparently of the cell or is just a
random thing that cells that manage to
organize your mitochondria better at the
front of the cell before entering the
channel are better of movement
and it appears that
so
we run this experiment where we have
alternative narrow channels and blood
channels
and the cells
when they get into [ __ ] channel they
have the option of reshuffling the
mitochondria and then they go to a
narrow channel where they can
grow more efficiently they have
mitochondria as the front as you see in
this movie or less efficiently if they
have mitochondria it's back
and then we studied uh for different
cell lines
how
what is the difference in velocity going
to this corrugated variegated channels
between cells that have mitochondria at
the front
and cells that have mitochondria at the
back
and it
it's again
obvious that the celsius mitochondria at
the front pointed by the red arrow they
move faster and more efficiently through
this
channels than the cells might conjure
its back
um
is um
is this something that is just a
correlation between words mitochondria
is localized or is there a cause-effect
relationship that we can establish
and for this we relied on some
techniques where we disrupt
this transport of mitochondria inside
the cell by
changing the shape and size of the
mitochondria
for
mitochondria when they are transported
inside the cell they have to be broken
divided into smaller mitochondria and
then they are transported to a location
in the cell and reassembled into larger
mitochondria that are more effective
if we interfere with processes called
fission and infusion
we can have
cells that have smaller mitochondria for
example by enhancing the fission of
mitochondria
or you can have or by
disrupting fusion
or you can have cells with larger
mitochondria by disrupting fission
like shown here for this mutant deer
b1
or we can promote the fusion
as shown
at the bottom for a
mutant opal one
and
when we
did these mutations where we promote or
inhibit each of this
we
we verified first that
yes mitochondria are larger if we
disrupt fusion we promote fusion
and then
we tested how well the cells migrate to
channels
and on the left you see some movies of
house cells multiple channels and
uh on the right you see is the
population averages
so for the cells shown in black
that
heavy disruption
in the ability of mitochondria to break
apart
these cells move at an average lower
speed
and
less resistance than the cells
uh you know of the wild type and then
again if we promote the fusion and make
all the mitochondria in the cell large
we see the same effect
with the cells moving slower and
less persistent
and in control experiments you verify
that the ability of
cells
mitochondria to produce atp
is being preserved throughout this
manipulation and you can read more about
this study in our physical journal paper
published last year
i want to end with this slide that
summarizes all the learnings that we
have from
looking at the migration of
cells in particular
is localization of mitochondria so we
have a system where you can make very
precise measurements
of
uh cell motility this
measurements are relevant for individual
and then we observe this
wide heterogeneity in how the cells move
and
we can segregate the
motility phenotype also moving cells
based on mitochondrial localization
it's showing this picture in red these
are cells that move fast
and persistent and then
they have mitochondria at the front
and then
we see once the other end of the
spectrum says that you might hundreds
back we are moving
slow and less persistent
so this tells us that it is
possible we don't know how but it is
possible
that if we
change
if we interfere with ourselves
we will be able to make them move slower
and less persistence
and this difference could be
by an order of magnitude
as the cells
got more fast and persistent let's say
average speed 60 microns an hour
with a persistent 0.8
they will
need about 125 days to reach 15
centimeters to a lymph node
while in the same
cell
line in employment population cells that
have mitochondria back
they would need
10 times more to reach the same distance
20 microns i mean in our average
velocity 0-25 persistence
that makes
about
1200 days
and
this order of magnitude difference is
one that is meaningful in cancer
if
let's say in theory if this
migration
is relevant
to the metastasis of cancer you may have
a difference
between
three months
to some
event
and three years and that's a meaningful
difference for any cancer patient
with fears i'll conclude i have to
thank
several people that worked with me on
this project
over time uh dr salim desai
dr yan wong khali sherbert
um
dr minnetoner director of our center
a number of collaborators from the
cancer center and
this was
research was enabled by funding from the
nih
and i'll be happy to take questions it
looks like we run out of time but i'll
stay here and try to answer as many
questions i can in the following 10-15
minutes
if you have more questions you can
always email me and if you are
interested in this kind of research
you can
go online and sign up for the world
surveys
okay so let's go through the questions
um
what image tool are using takes to sell
video um all these
images are being taken on automated
microscope that has a motorized stage
and
it has a camera that has ability to take
time lapse images so you can do this
today
with modern equipment pretty much with
any microscope uh you need to have an
incubator on the stage to keep the cell
at 37 degrees celsius otherwise
their migration is not going to be
happening
did we test the cells maze with bacteria
no we didn't we are
interested in doing that so
you can send me an email and we can work
something together
if you understand the principles
um
any cell
eukaryotic prokaryotic that does three
things
uptake something from
media
at the high enough rate to create a
diffusion gradient around it and then be
able to respond
to this gradient if obviously conditions
are checked then that
cell is going to migrate the same way
it's going to figure out the way through
amaze
the one cells take the same path
and
how about
having two or three open outlets
no
cells have still have quite a lot of
variability between them even in the
decision making and that's why for
example when we run
the best oriented cell that we have what
about 70
orientation it means 70 cells go
on a certain thousand 30 make
uh random
decisions or they make a random decision
at one point
so no not all the cell takes the same
path if we had three or
four outlets you'll have
the cells reaching out through all of
those outlets
uh do you have any data about the role
of egf uptake during migration for the
human liver tumor cells
no we didn't test any
liver
cells yet but we'll be happy to so sign
up for our
race and we'll be able to test this
can this experiment be modified to
include the population of uncertain
unsensitized and sensitized immune cells
to study
siemens interaction i guess
uh yes definitely we
are
working on different projects where you
look at interaction between cells
in this environment because it's
something that we can
do we can track individual cells
different phenotypes at different
origins and look at the interaction
between cells and quantify these
interactions
cancer cells have
very
disoriented site risks
cytoskeletal assemblies
has a
very regular shape
how do they
manage to migrate so aptly well that's
that's a question for the molecular
biologists we'll be happy to work with
you on figuring out that answer
what i think is happening is yes cells
have
disorganized cytoskeleton when they are
on a flat surface
but what's uh
confinement to a channel does it it
forces the cell to organize in a much
better and that seems to be
that could be the explanation for it's a
persistent movement
that the cell can undertake for hours
and hours
uh does cellular polarity have anything
to do with specific
patterns have you looked the proteins
involved
in cellular polarity uh
no we didn't
test it yet it's the most that we did
looking inside the cell was to look at
location of
mitochondria so far
is mitochondria
in the mitochondria what is the
abundance of proteins involved in
cellular polarity
this relation between mitochondria and
cellular polarity is one that is not
that well studied
this knowledge is
still emerging there are
many laws that are specialized in
studying mitochondria and location of
mitochondria inside of cells
we are
happy to collaborate with people
interested in this sort of questions
is motility synonymous with diffusion
velocity
um
the answer
is
no
in for our essay
and the reasoning is that you have
persistent migration
let's say for a channel that is 600
microns long you have persistent
migration
try to go back to smoothie it helped
very persistent migration for a long
time
and
because of that
this doesn't fit
the
equations of diffusion
so no the answer is no motility is
different than diffusive velocity
last question uh did you alter the
surface receptors and observe
the change in the pattern velocity
yes
if you look
if you read our
paper in integrity integrated biology
and
let me see where those results are
in 2010
nope not this one
here we go
um
irisa is a drug that interferes with the
signaling through the egfr receptor
and the other thing that we did is
we change the concentration of the
ligand for the receptors the egf
concentration in the media and the
threat differences
we didn't do anything more drastic or
more creative than this so
i'll be happy to talk more with you
okay well i think
if there are no more questions uh thank
you very much for your attention and i
hope you'll
look for our presentations again and
tell your friends about our work thank
you goodbye
you